wollen anfangen mit dem fall der
vermissten maddie christian b gilt
weiterhin als tatverdächtiger die
ermittler gehen davon aus dass der gehen
davon aus dass der 43 jährige die kleine
maddie getötet hat doch könnte christian
b sogar ein serientäter sein
ermittler prüfen laut medienberichten
jetzt ein zusammenhang mit den immer
noch spurlos verschwundenen kleinen rené
der kleine verschwand 1996 im alter von
sechs jahren im sommerurlaub an der
portugiesischen algarve zu dem zeitpunkt
lebte der tatverdächtige christian b
schon in portugal
und genau darüber möchte ich jetzt mit
bild reporter kai feldhaus sprechen er
ist mehr jetzt live zugeschaltet kai wie
kann es sein dass jetzt schon wieder ein
vermisstenfall aufgerollt wird und was
spricht in diesem fall gegen christian b
es liegt auf der hand dass das sämtliche
fälle die in einem zeitlichen oder
räumlichen zusammenhang stehen
verschwindens fälle von kindern jetzt
nochmal genau
und tatsächlich ist rené aus elsdorf das
liegt in nordrhein-westfalen im
sommerurlaub im juli 1996 verschwunden
als er mit seiner mutter und ihrem
lebensgefährten in algier am strand war
als isu ist knapp 30 kilometer von praia
da luz entfernt wo man erkennt
verschwand und wo auch christian b zu
der zeit lebte die familie saß in einem
restaurant
der junge lief ford zum strand und war
dann urplötzlich verschwunden und fanden
und doch seine anziehsachen und seine
badelatschen
es ist allerdings etwas anders gelagert
in diesem fall als bei maddie mccann
denn es gibt für diesen verschwindens
fällt für den fall rené eine plausible
erklärung was passiert sein könnte was
bei mänteln erkennen ja in den letzten
13 jahren nicht passiert ist wir waren
vor drei jahren an dem an dem ort des
verschwindens das ist eine kleine bucht
die liegt eingefasst von zwei bühnen
oben auf den dünen sind jeweils
strandboden aber wir reden vom atlantik
das heißt da ist ordentlich gelungen da
ist ordentlich da ist ordentlich
wellengang und wind und die ermittler
und auch ein großteil der familie geht
wohl in bol bisher davon aus dass rené
ertrunken ist man hat allerdings niemals
seine seinem körper gefunden
und der ist auch niemals für tot erklärt
worden